okay so we are getting into justice Lee
the Justice Doom ward and initially I
thought doing this video like doing that
this story arc is a singular story arc
unto itself but for a lot of people who
are reading either you're the villain or
just the the Justice League events
itself or at least getting caught up it
can all be really confusing right in
terms of like Perpetua and the
multiverse and all these forces and
everything that are going on I so the
cool thing about this is that while
other writers like Joshua Williamson is
writing the flash and he's using like
you know there's kind of the the
induction of these other forces you know
the still force and and sage force and
so on and so forth we're gonna kind of
ignore that not insofar is it's not in
an continuity or not in existence I mean
it is but we're gonna kind of ignore
what's going on there and we're gonna
focus strictly on what's happening here
because what scott snyder really does is
essentially explain it all and the
reality of this is it's kind of the
question why did DC wait so long and
this really kind of reveals it in terms
of the events going on here but the cool
thing about it is that this really picks
up with the idea between the Justice
League and the the Legion of Doom going
to war against each other and a reality
that's how it is that the events of year
the villain are set up right like you're
the villain is interesting insofar as as
like you know the offer of Lex Luthor
right basically like he travels around
from place to place to various villains
essentially and offers them you know
that makes the offer like do they want
to join his Legion of Doom The Joker
turned it down and in a lot of a lot of
ammo turn it down but a lot of them have
also accepted it too and so as a result
of that it's basically you know the the
the offer set of events are the offers
storyline in DC is really more just like
back up features like one page you know
or two page parts at the end of a story
where where Lex Luthor is basically
building up his own Legion of Doom
that's really all it is and in reality I
wouldn't have called it like year of the
villain I will just call it like the
rise of the Legion of Doom or something
like that you know and it just would
have tied into and made a lot more sense
in terms of like if only you know only
because of its namesake but at the very
least here with Lex Luthor forming his
own Legion of Doom for the purpose of
basically serving Perpetua and then the
Justice League standing against him
that's kind of where things are at the
moment so what this does is it actually
picks up seemingly like with the battle
with the war seemingly over right like
the the Legion of Doom having basically
won and what's cool about this is we get
this depiction of Lex Luthor who
basically uses all these forces at his
disposal right like the Silph force the
ultraviolet lantern forces you guys who
were unfamiliar remember the ultraviolet
lanterns are basically lanterns who can
bring out essentially the worst in
people right like all the raw negative
emotions are all kind of brought to the
surface unlike most
the other Lantern cores that really get
their power from a central power battery
the ultraviolet Lantern core is
basically fed by Umbridge this beam that
existed outside the source wall and then
once the source wall was broken made its
way into the main DC universe again
we've got a video on like what the
ultraviolet lanterns are so you'll find
that down in the description if you want
a more nuanced and a more detailed
explanation there but the long and short
of it is that everything that's going on
right now that is to say Lex Luthor
basically killing all the members of the
Justice League basically destroying any
opposition that he has is really more of
a vision of sorts that's given to them
by will paint by star man right and this
is important because what it does is it
basically shows the Justice League this
is what you guys are gonna be dealing
with this is what you guys are gonna be
coming with at the moment this is how
bad things are popping off and so what
the way this plays out it's really
interesting the way this plays out is
will Payton basically says like like in
order to essentially pull this off if we
faced off against Lex Luthor as he
stands now we'll lose just because of
the fact that his his that the fraction
of the totality the device that
basically allowed him to essentially
bring back Perpetua and in turn allows
two seemingly channel some of his energy
or at least most of his energy is much
bigger than will Payton's basically so
essentially like he can tap into more
that power than will Payton camp and so
the argument is we need to go to like
two different points in time outside of
the present day in order to access these
various you know remainders of the of
the totality remember this is an
artifact that when it came flying
through in and landed on earth in the
main DC Universe it also breached the
barriers of space and time just because
of the fact that space and time are
synonymous you can't have one without
the other and so it basically left
fractions of itself throughout the time
stream and the two big fractions they
need would equal a power or seem to
rival the power of Lex Luthor and give
them a fighting chance and so because of
that what the Justice League ends up
doing is basically bringing together the
entirety of its team right like the
whole totality of its team you've got
Shazam here you've got like like Black
Canary you've got Supergirl you've got
all these various characters here um all
of whom are are essentially like
fighting on behalf of the Justice League
and trying to see this mission come to
its fruition now this is where the
explanation begins to come into play and
this is why it matters so much is
because what we end up finding out here
from will paint in the way this plays
out is that at some point or another
Perpetua was basically created by what
was called this source right and the
source it's one of these things that
DC's never fully bothered to like go on
and explain in its entirety if you go
back and you read the old Jack Kirby
comics right the old fourth world comics
and things like that the source
basically God but then you go into like
the Vertigo line and then like God is
there like like it's called the presence
right so like God actually exists for
the most part dc's kind of treated it
insofar as the source is essentially God
to a degree and then like God has
different aspects right so like God's
judgment comes in the form of the
Specter different things like that
DC really treats their kind of source of
creation as a little more ambiguous the
regardless of the circumstance the idea
behind this was that the source
essentially created Perpetua alongside
of a host of other individuals that
would go forward and essentially create
like universes and multiverses right
they would create life so very celestial
esque from Marvel Comics in terms of
their form and function the difference
is that unlike unlike the the
individuals that she fought beside or at
least kind of existed beside perpetual
wanted to bring down the various you
know I guess parents for lack of a
better word and this essentially led to
her creating like what would eventually
become humans and Martians right in the
sense that as Lex Luthor existent exists
now he's what perpetual originally
created and then in turn they basically
split off as time went on then you got
humans and he got Martians as a result
of that Lex Luthor has kind of the first
step in a return to the the various kind
of source of beings that Perpetua
created ultimately this led to a kind of
civil war sorts where you had Perpetua
facing off against the monitor the
anti-monitor and the forger of worlds
and they in turn imprisoned her behind
the source wall because that with the
new multiverse basically being created
as it exists now kind of wiping away
what she did and then the the monitor
anti-monitor in the the forger of worlds
creating like a new multiverse this
basically leads to things as they exist
at the moments that's why you have the
Speed Force you've got the emotional
spectrum as it exists the various
Lantern cores it exists out there
everything outside of the ultraviolet
lanterns basically you've got the sphere
of gods and presumably the rock of
eternity and all that kind of good stuff
what what will Peyton basically says is
on the other side of that coin are
basically all the the seven hidden
energies of creation as they were used
by Perpetua basically what she created
when she created her to her dark
multiverse basically like her evil
version of the multiverse more or less
and that's when you start getting into
into all the various forces that are
kind of coming into fruition now Riley
there's still force to Sage force all
that kind of good stuff those are all
the things that Lex Luthor can
essentially tap into if he's able to
harness like the full totality of what
he can do and that's why when you looked
at the beginning of the story the
Justice League was utterly destroyed
because they never really had a chance
to face off against such a sheer level
of power and so with that being the case
what you basically got here is
you have shored of the totality in the
past which the Justice League has to get
and then a shard of the totality in the
future with the Justice League has to
get and then bring them all together in
the present day and then presumably
they'll stand a fighting chance and so
it's a cool little moment here like when
you get this this explanation in terms
of how it all works which in reality
having like that condensed in a concise
explanation this kind of long overdue
right like having a whole one-shot comic
that explains it but doesn't in a murky
way is okay but at the end of the day
like you know especially me I do much
better when I have like a clear and
concise short explanation on something
so it'll have to like hunt all over the
place you're trying to decipher clues or
different things like that it's
interesting it kind of depends on the
story but the long and short of this is
that with Lex Luthor's Legion of Doom
fully assembled the other half of this
is they also know what the Justice
League is doing and the reason why is it
really comes out of the issue before
this which isn't super important I mean
it is important in so far as like what
you learned from it but basically djaro
had kind of taken over the the Justice
League to a degree nothing anything
insane it was like nefarious or anything
like that but djaro is a small piece of
Starro and Starro had been destroyed at
one point but is basically regrowing
under the control of Lex Luthor and so
because star au is regrowing he's able
to reach out into his smaller little
tidbits there here and there which comes
in the form of djaro and because djaro
had taken over the minds of the Justice
League it means that djaro read their
minds and in turn star ov now knows
everything that Justice League is going
to do so essentially this battles done
before it's won and it's kind of a it's
a cool little moment there because what
it does is it creates a branch right it
creates the ability for the the Legion
of Doom to essentially use star au as a
means to spy on his djaro counterpart
and then watch the Justice League all
the time so this whole discussion that
they've had this whole plan that they've
put together you know with the help of
will Payton is all now known by the
Legion of Doom and so it's basically
like okay so like there is it seemingly
screwed
they're basically screwed like there's
really not much they can do at the same
time they've also got a saboteur in
their ranks that when the portals are
created that allow them to enter into
the timestream is basically sabotage
they don't end up exactly where they're
supposed to or at least it doesn't seem
to be the case right you end up picking
up with Jon Stewart and you pick up with
the flash both of whom are you know
arrived in the past but they don't
arrive in the past as it's supposed to
exist right now they arrive in the past
as it has already been conquered by
Perpetua and Oliver of various forces
right so it's one of these these weird
little scenarios because Hypertime in DC
is is really like an over complicated
mess it was the attempt of DS
see to basically keep what they did
after crisis on Infinite Earths right
before crisis on Infinite Earths you had
a multiverse you had multiple realities
each one having its own version of the
Justice League or any number of
combinations right having no Justice
League at all having just like a series
of heroes here and there and different
things like that when crisis on Infinite
Earths happened
DC eliminated all of that by they said
okay there's only one universe the issue
is that it limited the heck out of their
ability to write stories right like how
do you write stories that are
interesting where they go to a far-flung
future they go to some scenario where
things played out differently and and so
on and so forth and so wounded up
happening is with Mark Waid and a couple
others DC invented hyper time and hyper
time if you can imagine it in your head
is one of these points where if you
start from point A and you go to point B
if you look at it as a single time line
it's just point A to point B it's a
straight line that's basically it with
hyper time what you get is point a and
then you curve up and come down to point
B and that curve is like some alternate
reality where the flash killed everybody
and then you've got one where it curves
down from point A to point B and that
curve is an alternate reality where
Superman killed everybody it's a way for
DC to basically say there's alternate
timelines and they all branch off from a
singular point in time but they all
coalesce and basically arrive in a
guaranteed future they're there but it's
like they're not there right I mean it's
like one of those things work no matter
what you do you can't change it
essentially there's no way to undo that
timeline it's I think it's kind of murky
and I think it's a mess and I think it's
unnecessary and I think it's complicated
in reality I either pick alternate
realities and just go with the Marvel
formula or don't right it's just
Marvel's formula for alternate realities
is infinitely easy to understand right
like branch universe theory if it exists
there exists an alternate reality for it
and then alternate reality exists
because something in the main Marvel
Universe happened that caused it but
regardless of the situation you also end
up picking up with Superman Wonder Woman
and Batman who of course are sent into
this future and in turn like when they
arrived there this hotel he's conquered
everything and of course they're rescued
by kid command II now the character of
command II uh I guess command e I mean
command E I'm not really you know III
call it command E maybe it's came and II
I'm not a hundred percent sure how you
pronounce it but he basically comes from
an old-school comic that was actually
self titled command e commanding the
ongoing series which was lost in 1972 um
technically it was called command e the
last boy on earth and the way this
played out was that in this alternate
reality which I think was designated
earth 86 I'm not gonna swear to that I
want to say there's two different
iterations there's earth 86 and earth
295 but basically that the long and
short of it was that after this natural
disaster
especially when it came to like
radiation the fallout of nuclear war
this essentially permeated a handful of
animals both being experimented on by a
particular doctor as well as whatever
animals were left around the environment
and over the course of time it became
anthropomorphic so think Planet of the
Apes except more than just Apes and in
turn these this basically led to Kamandi
being the last boy who was left on earth
the last human being of sorts what Scott
Schneider really seems to be doing here
which I'm not avidly against it is
taking the concept of command E and then
just rolling it in right now and just
kind of saying okay here's a more
updated depiction of the character he
hails from a universe where the great
Cataclysm the great you know disaster
that was prophesized by the people who
inhabited earth at the time before it
all took place was actually the arrival
of Perpetua and essentially the
recreation of the multiverse why we can
just kind of go with that and take it as
an explanation it works
commanding obscure enough where where
Scott Steiner can really kind of do what
he wants with him and then just sort of
call it a day most people probably never
heard of them or I'd never heard of the
character or anything along those lines
but the fact remains and that when it
comes to this the arrival of the league
here and basically being saved by these
animal men essentially indicates that
there is some measure of resistance
against the forces of Perpetua and lex
luthor and so on and so forth which kind
of makes sense right I mean it'd be
somewhat bleak and really hopeless if it
turned out to be like a forever I'm
sorry a future what was what was that um
um I keep on to say future imperfect but
that's not right it's not it's not
called future imperfect what is it
called oh my god Gordon do not delete
this segment like people have to
understand how my brain works and me
trying to figure these things out
because I feel like there's fans right
now who are screaming the name into
their monitors and or spewing the name
into their phones or whatever and I'm
just sitting here like struggling um
it's not future's end I think it is
features and I think that's what it's
called I can't remember ah I got a
little bit into it and I was like this
is garbage
and then closed it which I imagine most
people won't disagree with littles gonna
be like you were kind of right to make
that call that story's pretty bad ah but
it'd be it'd be different if it was
something bleak like that right we're
like everybody's screwed basically
ah but to have a kind of resistance
force basically means it like there's
still remnants out there there's still
factions out there and if it's
commanding any animal men well then
there could be various other individuals
out there now it could also just be like
Scott Schneider using this as a way to
just kind of springboard
okay a new command e-series you know
just kinda like we're gonna talk about
commanding now and and whether or not
that that's popular kind of remains to
be seen but here's the big takeaway from
this right here's the big
the big thing for all this and when I
saw this it like I almost popped it was
insane like I got I got to this and I
was just like oh like holy cow right so
like you pick up with with Jon Stewart
and with the flash and with this this
future they're looking at you know in
this this landscape so obviously we're
talking about two different futures but
with this future that they're looking at
in this landscape like everything seems
to be just like totally you know kind of
collapsed and what's left of
civilization is living in like huts and
these little makeshift buildings and
different things like that and suddenly
they're met by the arrival like they
they have like this giant green ring
that circles around them and it's just
like okay so like what are the world is
going on and my first thought when I saw
this is all like okay cool like other
guys who are gonna be against who are
gonna be against like Perpetua and lex
and all them and whatever this
multiverse is or there's kind of
existing in this universe whatever this
universe happens to be I'm kind of
curious who these guys are gonna be lets
heard the page instead it was the
Justice Society of America and I was
like what in the hell like I was a dude
man let me tell you something yeah I was
do my mind was blown always like dude
this is bonkers man who the JSA and
here's the thing it's the whole JSA
right like Sandman Johnny Thunder like
Jay Garrick uh Alan Scott dr. fate I was
dude Hawk man I was like what in the
world is going on that guy who's like
the Panther looking guy that I never
cared enough to learn about like it's
it's crazy to see that I was like dude
this is this is nuts man so like the JSA
is not really back in so far as they're
back in the main DC Universe I think
that's confined to Geoff Johns but we
get to see the JSA man who cares how
they appear man these dudes could all be
wearing underpants and I would be like
JSA son let's get to it
did I be hyped okay so we are finally
getting back into the Justice Doom war
by Scott Snyder we are getting into part
two part DOS and this is gonna be kind
of a big one here right there's a lot
going on but as a bit of a refresher for
people who are unfamiliar right because
it took us a little while to kind of get
back into this what you basically have
here the kind of big overarching thing
is the return of Perpetua and the reason
why we say the return is because
Perpetua was the one who created the
multiverse right this at least this
particular multiverse in DC Comics and
the idea was that she was essentially
not really governed by so much as ruled
over or assisted by these kind of apex
predator soldiers now eventually she was
defeated by the combined forces of the
monitor the anti-monitor and the forger
of worlds and so following her defeat
and her imprisonment within the source
wall it then turned to the monitor the
you monitor in the forger of worlds to
begin creating kind of like a new
multiverse that basically you know ended
up in its current form as it exists now
and of course included things like you
know Infinite Crisis Final Crisis crisis
on Infinite Earths different things like
that but the idea was that perpetuo has
basically been released by by Lex Luthor
and Lex Luthor is kind of reverted back
into one of her apex predators right now
the way this played out was originally
these predators were ultimately split
but when one part of them kind of became
humans the other part became martians
and so with lex luthor absorbing martian
manhunter that's how we kind of reverted
back into this sort of apex version of a
character for these kind of soldiers
that were used by Perpetua in order to
rule the unit of rule the multiverse and
her vision of the multiverse is a dark
place right it's a very dark and very
harsh environment and so in order to
keep this this victory from happening by
the Legion of Doom what is it up
happening is that the Justice League was
really split into two parts one part
basically went into the past the other
part went into the present and then
another part basically stayed into a
state in the present day but the idea is
that they're essentially traveling
throughout the entire time stream to
find these these artifacts these pieces
of the totality which can be assembled
and be used which is their only real
chance of defeating Perpetua because of
the fact that it has so much incredible
power and so the the version of the
Justice League that went into the past
include the flash Green Lantern the Jon
Stewart and so on ended up running into
the Justice Society of America and
that's where this picks up now here's
the important thing to understand here
and here's kind of the interesting thing
about this is a lot of this is being
viewed by Brainiac quite being a
brainiac basically kind of continuing on
the path of bottling up cities different
things like that but we don't really
know exactly what his role is in all
this and so far as you know outside of
the part of the Legion of Doom and
bottling of worlds and ensuring the
Justice League can't find the the
totality and the various aspects of the
timestream it basically leads to like
the JSA and in this version the Justice
League encountering each other but
they've never met and they don't know
who the other is and this is kind of an
important thing right because one part
of this really kind of leads into the
idea of Doomsday Clock which is to say
the fact that ten years from these
heroes Matan memories were basically
missing but the other part of this is
that technically the JSA doesn't exist
in DC and the reason why is because if
you guys remember from Doomsday Clock
the JSA was formed by Green Lantern Alan
Scott but because of the fact that dr.
Manhattan had basically intervened and
Alan Scott died before he could attain
his Green Lantern the JSA was never
formed and so there was no indication
that characters like Jer
or any of those guys ever existed now
Doomsday Clock will likely rectify all
of that when the final issue comes out
but as it stands at the moment very does
not know who Jay Garrick is and Jay
Garrick does not know who variants and
this is a particularly interesting
continuity error considering the fact
that very Allen during the events of the
button knew who Jay Garrick was right so
that's why things are kind of finicky
here that's why things are kind of funny
it's a little strange in terms of how it
all comes together this is likely just a
massive continuity error by DC but the
cool thing about this is that for people
who were fans of the JSA you get to see
them in spectacular fashion y-you get to
see Jay here you get to see Allen Scott
really being the kind of heroes that
they were now in terms of of why they're
in this particular point in time either
in this era we don't know explicitly
when this time hearing takes place we
simply just know that it's in the past
but before we get into that what we're
gonna do is we're gonna switch over to
command II basically the the last human
being alive on earth in this future
where you have Batman Superman Wonder
Woman and so on and animals are really
kind of risen up now of course we
covered how all this transpired in the
first video so you want me to go check
that out to kind of get the origin of
how this future ended up the way that it
was but of course they're immediately
set upon by all these members of these
Brainiac robots and so on and so forth
these kind of police force or
what-have-you but essentially what you
end up getting here is basically them
tracking down and trying to locate the
Hall of Justice and it's kind of a cool
little thing here because once they're
able to locate that locate the Hall of
Justice itself and once you're able to
kind of initiate their plan ultimately
it allows them actually leave this
universe and start traveling to the
other universes that Brainiac has at his
disposal and the reason why is because
the totality could be in any one of
those and that's what really makes a
situation so hairy is because what
they're looking for is essentially a
needle in a stack of needles right I
mean they they literally have to go
through every single one of these
universes that that Brainiac has and try
to find the totality in each one right
so it's gonna be kind of a kind of a
crazy thing because totality is only in
one of them right and that's where
things kind of get crazy and kind of get
bonkers is because ultimately they have
to use this kind of beacon of source to
try to locate it would it be insanely
difficult to find now of course at the
same time you've got the present-day
Justice League which is to say the
forger of worlds and the monitor
alongside a hot girl and so on who
basically go into bleed space right
because their idea is to locate the
anti-monitor
now those are guys who are familiar with
bleed space the bleed itself in DC is
essentially the space between universes
right so it's like if I took a whole
bunch of golf balls and I put them in a
of water all that water represents the
bleed right the space between the
different universes and each one of
those golf balls is a universe itself
right so that's really all that is now
normally you're talking about an
extremely dangerous place to try to
navigate through man I mean you can't
take any any kind of technologically
advanced vessel from from DC or from the
main DC universe and just fly into bleep
space and be fine
it would probably tear it to pieces
right that's the reason why you have the
the multiversal Justice League for
example which uses a specialized ship in
order to do it and this particular
vessel has been retrofitted by the
forger of worlds and the monitor in
order to try to try to maintain and
sustain itself while they're traveling
through the bleep but there's no
guarantee but the cool thing about this
this is kind of it kind of an
interesting take away from this is that
what you end up getting is basically
this this kind of recollection or at
least as this instance whereby when
Superman and his forces travel from one
of the universes of Brainiac into
another they essentially end up
encountering a group that that really
refers to themselves as the Justice
League in a now Justice Legion a also
stands for Justice Legion Alpha and long
time DC fans will immediately recognize
this group because this is the version
of the Justice League from DC 1 million
and that's kind of the dangerous thing
about this because what it shows is that
as part of the Legion part of the Legion
of Doom from Lex Luthor what Brainiac
has been doing is running all throughout
the timestream and basically capturing
all these different universes or all
these little portions of a universe from
all throughout the time stream right
from the very very distant past all the
way up to the distant future and so
that's what makes things so crazy and
that's why they have to jump from one
container basically to the next trying
to find the totality where wherever it
may be among all these different
universes it's an insane kind of goal to
have to achieve but the Justice League
and alpha is an exceedingly powerful
team right because in a DC 1 million
landscape the Justice League really
evolved beyond its role of being a
protector of the world and instead it
evolved out to become a protector of the
galaxy and so justice Legion alpha had
this base of operations on Jupiter and
they're charged with protecting the
solar system right so basically what
you're getting here is the the DC 1
million team which is kind of cool to
see them return here at the same time
and I don't know how I really feel about
this
we basically end up finding out that the
this this particular group of the
Justice Society of America of course is
operating in 1945 during World War two
and the Legion of Doom forces who have
made their way into the past really kind
of try to cut off the superhero team
are basically piloting Japanese planes
in order to attack Pearl Harbor which is
kind of a it's kind of a crappy thing to
do I think kind of weird kind of strange
but the reason why you had the JSA
during 1945 is because when you had the
JSA originally in DC they were basically
like an earth 1 and alternate reality
team I mean originally they were world
war two characters but when DC created
the multiverse they basically said okay
so essentially like all the superheroes
well I guess the version of the Justice
League that Jay Garrick was a part of on
earth too and this new Justice League is
on earth one that's basically it when
you got to crisis on Infinite Earths the
entire multiverse was wiped away and the
JSA went with it right because there was
no alternate reality there would be no
basis for the JSA to exist but it did
have a huge fan base and so what DC did
is they came back with the
reintroduction of the JSA and what they
said was that the JSA fought during
World War two they were basically
superheroes who existed during the 1940s
and 1950s and so by the time Superman
rose to promise while the time Clark
Kent moved to Metropolis and became
Superman by the time that Bruce Wayne's
parents were murdered he went trained
and then came back to Gotham became
Batman by the time all these modern era
superheroes rose to prominence the JSA
had been retired and so when when you
got to the events before the new 52 in
2011 the JSA was basically a bunch of
retired superheroes who came out of
retirement and back into active
superheroing again and that's how you
got those teams unified together it's
why you see them here during World War
two oh this was really kind of a kind of
a bookend way I think for Scott Snyder
to kind of bring the JSA back and say
well this is probably how they're gonna
return yes they were they were during
World War Two and what's likely going on
here during doomsday clock especially
when we saw by Johnny Thunder and
characters like that who were originally
part of the JSA as their minds were
white they don't know who they are
characters like Jay Garrick were removed
and filled into the Speed Force and all
the other members of the JSA don't know
who they are like Alan Scott's dead
Johnny Thunder is stuck in an insane
asylum everybody thinks he's crazy when
he's saying that like he's got crazy
powers and so on and so forth Jay
Garrick see the Speed Force in any other
members of the JSA had likely had their
memories wiped by Manhattan which is why
they're not active anymore right so I
mean there's there's all kinds of little
things that can go into it little
tidbits here and there they can really
kind of clear all this up but what it
does is it basically shows us kind of
going into this this tale a little bit
here it shows us that essentially
Aquaman is working on behalf of the
anti-monitor that during the the story
where Aquaman was supposed to have died
the drowned earth event where Aquaman
was supposed to have been removed in
killed off the what the anti-monitor did
was essentially save him and then turn
him into a henchman for himself now the
reason why that's the case actually
becomes prominent here in a minute and
the reason why and this is particularly
important is because there's a common
conversation that takes place between
Wonder Woman in command II basically
what is it going on here is that in this
future this DC 1 million future that the
Justice League temporarily faces off
against the Justice League in a it's not
a great big huge knock-down drag-out
fight instead they're basically fighting
these kind of year B's these other
forces out there and ultimately end up
defeating them but there's this
conversation when a woman has in the
sense that commanding comes from an age
when war is all they really know I like
war is what brought the downfall of
society but the world that he lives in
is harsh and it's really kind of nut
early every man for himself so much is
survived by whatever means you can and
so as a results that we're commodity
comes from is simply from is from a
future where you do have little
civilizations there in little pockets of
groups and things like that where people
do work together for the most part he's
used to a very harsh environment and so
when he looks back on the recollection
or at least on these these stories of
old right you know the world being funds
into war and things like that his
perception of the past is that all
humanity did was engage in war and so
when he met the Justice League and they
basically showed him that hey it's not
all just about warfare there's things
like compassion things like hope and
that's what warfare is predicated on we
fight these fights because we want to
ensure that people who are innocent
don't really end up getting caught in
these things but also because by
defeating these bad guys there's hope
for a better tomorrow it really kind of
seems to instill in the idea of Kimani
to simply not just run away this idea
that he's really kind of the only hope
they have insofar as he'll do what needs
to be done in order to help try to save
the day and so ultimately what is up
happening is one of the members of the
Justice League is housing their totality
itself and so because of the fact that
the intention once brainiac one-million
reveals himself where the intention is
to use this power to essentially take
out the Justice League in as well as the
Justice League of America incapacitate
them most likely forced them into
subservience by turning them into as his
soldiers or what-have-you but there's no
tality is taken by Wonder Woman and
given to command II and then basically
command II is sent out in order to
ensure the survival of the totality
that's exceedingly important what we end
up doing just jumping back to the past
and probably one of the coolest things
because where this whole battle is
raging during out during world war ii
you know with regards to the attack on
Pearl
Harbert all these soldiers that when the
USS Arizona is hit by a torpedo and and
sunk were under normal circumstances and
in real world history a litany of
soldiers died during that that whole
that whole scenario instead aquaman
comes to the rescue with a Kraken and
there's one of the coolest things right
I see him just like pop up with this
enormous Kraken but it's kind of a funny
thing because what he does is he tells
them like look I get you guys are here
to get the totality and that's cool and
everything but you can't succeed right
you there's no way you guys can win here
it's not really possible as it was kind
of a funny thing here because when when
you get this whole thing unfolding it's
like okay so like all fingers in all
scenarios according to the idea that
what the Justice League is doing is that
while they're trying their best there's
nothing they really can do there's
nothing they can do to win because the
power of Perpetua is growing every
second of every day and it's getting to
the point where it's basically
uncontainable right where it can't be
stopped
and so what you end up having is
Perpetua who basically travels with like
Lex Luthor directly to the very edge of
all things in existence and ultimately
meets with the anti-monitor and the
question is which side does the
anti-monitor choose and it's kind of a
cool thing here because you would look
at the anti-monitor as a character an
you would say okay so it's always been a
villain right the anti-monitor is led to
the destruction of the multiverse and
the first crisis on Infinite Earths
event and then while it didn't really
reappear in the traditional sense until
Darkseid war and as far as it actually
being a being that exists out there the
events of Darkseid were the events that
led up to it like forever evil saw the
anti-monitor traveling from one universe
to the next and continuing to wipe it
out right so he's always kind of been
this force of nature almost Galactus to
a degree but with a little more hint of
evil in it but when you have a scenario
unfold ultimately the inti monitor in
subsiding with the forger of worlds the
monitor and Earth's superheroes and so
what this shows is that essentially
everybody has it out for perpetual right
like everybody's against perpetuate here
but it's kind of a pool scenario because
the way that Scott Snyder plays this out
is okay but like they can't really win
anyway and it doesn't really even matter
and this is really kind of what it kind
of comes to a head when you end up
having the forger of worlds who goes to
attack Perpetua and nothing happens and
it's kind of a cool little moment
because what is up happening is of
course they basically end up merging
into the ultra monitor basically this
gigantic monitor unto itself like the
single ultra powerful beam that was one
of the forces are really kind of the
total force that ended up defeating
Perpetua in the first place but all
indications seem to point to the idea
that perpetuates power is
app or a little bit higher than it was
when they originally fun and so she
can't really be defeated in the
traditional sense instead it's going to
require more ability than what was
originally had in order to see her
defeated and so jumping back to the past
with regards to the Justice League
fighting alongside the JSA their journey
to find the totality after essentially
stopping the Legion of Doom to a degree
with regard to the attack on Pearl
Harbor is that what the Legion of Doom
appears to be incapacitated their
journey ends up taking them to Atlantis
and of course this kind of coincides
with the time in which Atlantis is king
is basically missing and so ultimately
the Legion of Doom makes their move only
to reveal that they've captured for
Simon and it's kind of a funny thing
here because when that happens at the
same time that takes place you end up
getting Vandal Savage
and as Legionnaires Club now Vandal
Savage and Legionnaires Club is a group
that we've seen in the early stories of
Scott Snyder's run on Justice League
there were after the totality and
managed to capture a portion of it and
so what this looks like and I'm not
going to swear to this as an absolute
truth but what this looks like is the
absolute past of the DC Universe this is
actually the past right so basically
they've they've gone into 1945 in the
past the main DC Universe meaning the
Justice Society of America existed
during that point in time which begs the
question why don't they exist now again
tying back into the events of Doomsday
Clock it's a cool little bit of a
revelation here but where you have the
where you have Brainiac 1 million who's
basically going off against the the
Justice League the Justice League
doesn't really seem to be able to defeat
it just because of the fact that
Brainiac 1 million is so incredibly
powerful or you've got the Justice
League in the present day who weren't
really able to do anything to stop
Perpetua and then you've got the
Legionnaires Club basically showing up
in the past it all really pointed the
idea the caffeine totalities even if
they can do it won't fix everything but
it doesn't look like they can it is not
looking they can actually capture the
pieces of the totality and save
everything so what it does is it all
falls down on the shoulders of
commanding and Kimani begins the
dressing basically this this particular
group out there this unseen you know
group out there and says like we need
more people here we're like we need more
help the Justice League as it exists now
is not powerful enough on their own we
need more forces here and that's what we
end up finding out the Kamandi is not
just talking to anybody
command he's actually talking to the
Justice League Unlimited group talking
to like Batman unlimited superman
unlimited all these characters DC's
taking the unlimited universe or at
least Scott Snyder is and rolling it
into the Justice League comics
this is amazing
okay so we are continuing on with our
coverage of the Justice League and of
course those guys remember what we've
talked about in the last couple videos
you basically have the the Justice
League split into a couple different
factions white one went into the future
which under why called the called the
Justice League beyond team the Justice
League Unlimited team I was excited
usually when I get excited I just say
things you know and and they're like
stuff comes out and the video goes out
and then people who are like always
looking through my videos trying to find
mistakes or like the first ones to find
it you also had a Justice League team
that went into the past any count of the
JSA now I want to clear the air on this
on the Justice Society of America as it
appears in Justice League and the de sá
as it appears in Doomsday Clock right
because until we got to the ending of
Doomsday Clock we didn't really know how
the JSA fit in anything and even then
even now that we have an explanation you
still run into a pretty big continuity
error with regards to what happened in
that story but the way this is the way
this plays out given the way the
Doomsday Clock number 12 ended the way
that this played out and you're kind of
making sense of all this is that dr.
Manhattan is all of you guys know had
moved the lantern out of the way of Alan
Scott right so Alan Scott never
discovered the Green Lantern pas the
result was that he was killed the train
crash and then never went on to become I
never went on to become a Green Lantern
that we know and then never formed the
Justice Society of America and that was
Geoff Johns explaining why the JSA never
existed throughout all the new 52 you
and the beginning of DC rebirth at the
end of Doomsday Clock dr. Manhattan put
the lantern back and so because the
lantern went back to where it was
supposed to be where Alan Scott went on
to discover it and then became the Green
Lantern he ended up saving the train
from the crash and then you know became
a superhero that we know and then
ultimately went on to form the Justice
Society of America and that's how the
team appears at the end of in the at the
end of Doomsday Clock because by
altering the past essentially which is
what dr. Manhattan did what it basically
meant is that it kind of created this
cascading effect right it altered the
timeline in such a way to where the JSA
had been there when they were supposed
to be there right so essentially this is
true what you're seeing here with issue
number 31 and the Justice League that's
how it is
after dr. Manhattan went back and
changed the timestream the issue that
you run into here with this continuity
err is that when you have that when you
have that issue where you had Barry
Allen and Jon Stewart talking to Alan
Scott and and Jay Garrick of the JSA
Barry Allen told Jay Garrick he's like
tell us who you are
and Jay Garrick's like well where are
the superheroes of the 1940s were the
Justice Society of America who were you
guys and and Barry Allen's like were
we're the Justice League you know so the
fact that the two groups didn't know
each other is it's kind of an issue but
only on one side right the JSA
Schneider establish you know where that
particular segment took place in the
past of the main DC Universe so it makes
sense the JSA would not know who the
Justice League are because the Justice
League would own them if the JSA are
there it means it takes place at the
events of Doomsday Clock meaning the JSA
had always been there and the JSA if the
JSA had always been there then it means
that the JSA you know that the memories
of the Justice League haven't been wife
were just to say the fact that they
didn't know who the JSA was because a
JSA was never there those memories
should have been restored by the time I
would have corrected itself the JSA was
always there the Justice League would
have remembered them because they would
have you know read about their stories
whatever the case was and the result was
of the Justice League Barry Allen you
know Jon Stewart those guys should have
known who the JSA were the fact that
they didn't is a continuity here it only
means what or either that or it means
that Doomsday Clock the conclusion of
Doomsday Clock takes place sometime in
the middle of scott Snyder's Justice
League which is kind of a hard sell
given how much happens in such a short
amount of time it would mean that in the
middle of all of Scott Snyder's Justice
League the entirety of Doomsday Clock
takes place and I'd have a hard time
believing that I don't really believe
that so again you kind of run into a
continuity error there but hopefully
this this wraps things up and this makes
sense you know Scott Steiner did an
interview with Newsarama where he said
the JSA as it appears in his Justice
League comic is when the team first
forms right so again like maybe was a
year or so after the team came together
which explains why they don't they don't
you know they're pretty new and and
pretty fresh but I've seen a few of
those questions floating around in terms
of how everything gets reconciled and
that's basically how all that works but
nonetheless you know with this JSA team
being there alongside the Justice League
of course we talked about how Vandal
Savage had shown up now Vandal Savage
and the the Legionnaires Club as he had
formed it was basically result of
analyst average trying to track down the
the the totality from now this goes all
the way back to Justice League number
one and I think number seven where he
basically gave us like a new origin of
Vandal Savage and all that kind of stuff
and his efforts to give that get the
Peace of the totality what ends up
happening from what we've seen with
regards to Vandal Savage is that
ultimately his fraction of the totality
if you guys when were all the way back
in the early run of Schneider is that
ultimately it's taken by by Lex Luthor
and Lex Luthor kills Vandal Savage but
that hasn't happened yet because they've
gone back before that took place in the
story but that's what Jon Stewart warns
a mouth like hey what you're doing here
is gonna get you killed
eventually Lex Luthor's gonna kill you
so basically you need to help us to keep
yourself from being killed writing
because Vandal Savage cherishes life
over over death he basically ends up
siding with the Justice League but what
it does is it allows them a way to
basically jump out you know
to kind of open a portal it will let
them get back to to their current time
and so at the same time what you also
have is in the future which is probably
the coolest parts of the story in the
future you have you know at least the
future of Metropolis you have the
Justice League that was said there right
so Batman Superman Wonder Woman who were
all of course captured by by Brainiac
one-million and all for the most part
they're gonna be destroyed and taken out
right but as we saw in the previous
video Kamandi had basically gone to like
all these different universes or at
least he'd only gone to the to the
Justice League beyond universe and then
like grab those superheroes only for us
to find out he's gone through all the
universes that are basically being held
captive by Brainiac which includes like
the Kingdom Come universe and the
Superman red Sun universe and like all
these different universes that are out
there and all these superheroes from
across the multiverse all band together
it's pretty huge in scope and so at the
same time that's going on of course then
you have the fight between hot girl and
Lex Luthor in the present day but
essentially at the far edge of the
universe we're all things are getting
ready to break loose right all all havoc
is getting ready to pop off now
ultimately because of the fact that
Hawkgirl is tied into the totality
meaning her power is necessary for star
man to achieve his goal which is to say
opening portals across like all these
different time streams so all these
superheroes once they basically grab
their charge of the totality can jump
through and then all end up in this
singular location to basically unite the
totality and face off against Perpetua
oh they can succeed and then ultimately
end up defeating her and it's kind of
crazy because like it looks like it's
about to work right like like hot girl
ends up intended to attack Lex Luthor
and then like the portals seem to start
opening up and like it's their chance to
win right like it's literally a scene
out of like Avengers in the game right
works just like all the portals start
opening and like one of the most epic
scenes ever in like movie history like
it's like one of the coolest things ever
it looks like they're all going to win
and that's literally yet like they
grabbed a little shards of the totality
people start getting through as fast as
they can the problem with this is
Hawkgirl because remember hot girls on a
quest for vengeance and that's the
problem because you had you basically
had Martian Manhunter who was absorbed
and then quote-unquote killed by Lex
Luthor and that's how Lex Luthor is in
his current his current form that's why
he looks the way he does because he's
basically the alpha predator he's what
people were in the universe before
Martians and human beings were split in
half and then went off to go do their
own things right Martians and human
beings used to be singular organisms and
so as a result of that she actually is
upside tracking from the mission and
then trying to destroy Lex Luthor's when
she believes he's not paying any
attention
but then ultimately you know where she
kinda says okay fine I'll stand off or
go go play my role he basically stabs
her and the moment when they need her
power it's not there and so the result
is that all these portals basically
start closing off again and the ability
for all these superheroes to unite in a
singular location combined with
basically all these humans and all these
various forces across the multiverse
really kind of siding with doom right
basically kind of giving up on justice
things like that and basically saying
like we side with doom we side with the
destruction of all things essentially
leads to perpetual rising to her
quote-unquote final form if that makes
any sense one of the other things that
she also does is we basically seen
remember the the monitor brothers the
forger of worlds the monitor and in the
ant the anti-monitor merging into the
ultra monitor this in turn basically
allows Perpetua to transform the three
of them allow the ante monitors
personality to take hold and then
restore him to his full totality
essentially giving us the anti-monitor
from crisis on Infinite Earths and this
is a really really cool moment here
right because we get the kind of a
return of a classic character but the
big takeaway from all this and the
reason why this matters is because what
this basically means is that with the
death of will Peyton Starman who's
killed by Perpetua and nobody really
there to kind of open these portals in
and bring everybody to this singular
location essentially all hope is
basically lost right and even among the
various superheroes themselves this
feeling of hopelessness almost kind of
seems to resonate right like the sigil
of Perpetual basically starts to emanate
across all these different worlds across
the main of the main DC universe not
only that it's not just the main DC
universe it's everywhere across all
realities in the entirety of the
multiverse so the ghost sector out there
where you have like Darkseid and the
Justice League Odyssey team where you
basically have like the the Polaris
system with the thanagarians you've got
the the Owens right the guardians of the
universe who are just coming okay so
like we need to recall all the all the
lanterns because we can't let Olaf fall
in the dark multiverse where you still
got Barbados chained up because he's
still alive he sees the whole sigil
unfold the crime syndicate of America
and earth 3 the ori of worlds basically
the the multiversal justice league team
and then you've even got the Gotham by
Gaslight universe which is which is
actually one of the first universes to
fall right Perpetua shows up and says
like side with me right like side with
doom or be destroyed and of course
because it's led by that man and so on
and so forth they sided with justice
ever pet you up wipes out the universe
she's just like done you guys are you
guys are all gone you guys are all that
that's basically it for all of you now
the crazy thing about this is that with
this universe essentially being
destroyed there's really no hope for
them right like again it's just the end
that's really how it looks it's like
there's no real chance for any of these
people to come out on top for any of
these guys to win and so with that in
mind what you end up having is Hawkgirl
out with her son Shane basically
realizing the mistake they made that
they essentially do or at least Hawkgirl
doomed the multiverse so in turn trying
to fly back through a portal trying to
get back to everybody else being
recalled by Batman and then of course
Perpetua basically damages the ship just
kind of leaves it derelict and floating
in space with no real indication that
Hawkgirl or her son are gonna be saved
by anybody like it really is just kind
of the fall of everything and that's
what's so good about this right is
because you feel the gravity of this
situation like for this fleeting moment
that the heroes of Earth had a chance to
win but in this fleeting moment one of
them makes a poor decision and it all
comes crashing down by this house of
cards all comes down and it all ends up
collapsing so what is up happening is
Batman Batman Wonder Woman and Superman
basically end up trying to see where
they can is sort of sort of spy on
Perpetua and when they do what they end
up seeing is a couple different things
going on especially Lex Luthor and the
Legion of Doom are kind of brought
before Perpetua and she tells each of
them like you all have a purpose to
serve right and so like they start
making these demands you're these
different things like that
Brainiac for example requests like a
repository of like all of history why he
wants to know everything that's ever
happened in the entirety of a multiverse
not just the universe but like the
entirety of the multiverse Gorilla Grodd
wants basically like seven planets to
control for himself you know and it's
kind of crazy because what she does is
she tells like she tells him all you all
have a have a world of surf you know and
we'll start with Brainiac and she turns
Brainiac into a chair she turns him into
furniture man they've just messed up she
literally just turns them into a throne
and and this is this is kind of the
crazy thing is because as this is going
down this kind of human side right you
know Lex Luthor starts to feel this very
human chill and it's just kind of like
but this is not how it's supposed to go
though like it feels like she's
betraying all of us and in reality
that's what was always going to happen
and that's what was always warned of Lex
Luthor do not side with Perpetua because
she'll turn against you and show you use
your for her own ends right like if you
are surviving your endeavors with her
it's because you're serving a purpose
she wants you to serve but what happens
when your purpose is done well then
there's no need for you anymore and so
as a result of that that's exactly what
happens Sinestro Gorilla Grodd
Cheeta is taken they're all basically
confined to these kind of vessels of
sorts and and literally Lex Luthor is
watching all of this unfold and it is
kind of what in the world is going on
only for us to find out all the various
powers they possess the life force bust
still force all these various forces
really the
if you guys remove the flash stories the
forces that escaped this escape the the
breaking of the source wall they are all
basically being channeled directly into
Lex Luthor and so as result so that it
does give him a huge amount of power and
this human element this this feeling
that he and his team are being betrayed
immediately goes away and now it's just
kind of like do this as a whole is the
whole of the piece because he's
basically been spared here and so in
response to this the Justice League kind
of seen this unfold actually changes
their tune and one of the smartest ways
what they end up doing is basically
looking at this and saying okay given
the power of Lex Luthor right now we
can't really defeat him head-on right we
can't really just like get into a
knock-down drag-out fight with him and
defeat him because he can basically
incapacitate us in any number of ways
the guy is a Swiss Army knife of powers
right he's a one-man army so if we try
to go against him he's going to crush us
all instead we have to fight him in a
way that he would normally never expect
we can't fight Lex Luthor as if he's Lex
Luthor in his battle armor facing off
against Superman we have to fight lex
luthor as he is now we have to reach
that human side of him we have to reach
that part of him that basically we can
we can sort of pull to the forefront and
get him to understand what's really
going on here it's like a meta battle
right like an emotional battle and it's
kind of a cool thing because Batman
basically gets on board as well as all
the various other superheroes because
it's the best plan they got who's gonna
say no to this and so of course the
anti-monitor is basically sent out to
destroy to destroy Hawkgirl and the and
the ship that they're on and then in
turn the flash basically tells John
Stewart hey here's this car get in this
car like lying out there you know this
the only thing that'll help you survive
out there it'll get you out there as
fast as possible almost immediately the
way they are and then save them right
because when you're talking about that
far out in space it would take John
Stewart days probably to get out there
you know flying at full power and even
then you'd have to stop at different
places and reach hard as ring they need
them like right now otherwise we're
gonna die and they're their struggle
against the anti-monitor
and is it being one of the coolest
things because of course Lex Luthor and
the Legion of Doom show up and like
they're armed their doom base their doom
Citadel or whatever it is and then
Batman ISM enacting this contingency
that he always had which was like the
Hall of Justice rising up out of the
ground and then like basically being its
own variant so it's only kind of design
a sort of like the the legion of Doom's
ship and it's like dude how awesome is
that like do this one of the coolest
things ever right like it's djaro it's
like it's an awesome measure and then
Batman's like yeah a final awesome
measure is though totally there's a
totally awesome measure djaro
it's gonna be lit I want to read a comic
where Batman
that like this is lit but what you
basically end up getting here is like
this massive battle between like the
forces of Lex Luthor and the forces of
like these Justice League superhero some
like across the multiverse right because
with what little portal what a little
access they've had they've been able to
kind of like hop in and create these
little these little skiff portals that
get them to where they need to go all
come on you're all confined in the Hall
of Justice but just take a look at this
for a second man like look at this like
full-page spread right like you got
Shazam you've got Supergirl you've got
like Superman 1 million all right and
then you have like Jay Garrick you've
got Damian Wayne who's a boss all these
superheroes just like charging you got
Guy Gardner running looking like a
goofball I give that all these all these
guys all these superheroes just like
hightailing it into this battle and it's
amazing right because like this is like
Scott Schneider is like final final
thing with Justice League right like
there's nothing else after this when he
finishes do more he's like I'm done now
and he's gonna put down the pin and
probably go work on JSA from what he
said in the interviews but like this is
ridiculously awesome right and so what
you have are kind of like the iconic
members of the Justice League you know
each of one representing different
aspects of the various forces trying to
bond together and trying to unite this
totality but the issue is that they're
just not powerful enough right they
don't really have the necessary forces
in order to do this right it's like a
person who's colorblind trying to trying
to complete a Rubik's Cube it's just not
gonna work right because they can't see
all the colors and it's exactly the way
this Justice League functions right I
mean they're they're capable in and of
their own right but ultimately they're
not really able to assemble this
totality the way they need to and so
what it does is it switches out into
space with with Hawkgirl and with her
son Shane trying to withstand this
assault of the anti-monitor and doing
pretty well but then suddenly like a car
horn comes out of nowhere right like the
anti-monitor turns around he's like
there's somebody here a car horn and
what I have what I'm hoping with this
car horn what I'm hoping is that like
the esses portal opens and this car
sounds like the swarm goes I was like
I'm really hoping that's what it sounds
like but while all this goes on the
impact of Jon Stewart and the force that
he wields basically ends up kind of
creating force in the anti-monitor to
disperse itself back into his three
forms right to the anti-monitor the
world forger and the and the monitor
itself restoring them to their normal
counterparts but also for the
anti-monitor kind of call out for help
and while you have Perpetua who's like
destroying a world or at least in the
process of destroying the world she
grabs it and just throws it at everybody
which is pretty boss right somebody that
powerful just throwing a world across
the cosmos you know and with the
intention of smashing people but the
cool thing about this is that Schneider
uses it really really well right the
idea is that with the world foragers
hammer he'd be able to like you know
essentially hit things hard enough to be
able to create a portal and so she
doesn't really have the power to do that
what it would do at least this impact
would be able to kind of create a space
rupture or at least a rupture in the
space-time continuum enough to work an
open kind of a gateway that would allow
them to pass through and so in essence
the the world forger appears to
sacrifice its life when this whole
process goes down but it's kind of a
cool moment right because John Stehr
were coming in basically saving them and
then risking everybody away is is a
pretty solid moment right I mean
literally the world foragers standing
there like these get ready to batter up
and just like smash this thing as it
hits the world right so the result of
this is it back on earth everything is
basically going to pot right I mean
again like all this is like almost all
the superheroes are fawn they're
fighting as best they can but they're
not really capable of holding off
against the various forces of the Legion
of Doom and at the same time once hot
girl arrived you know once she shows up
there with her son Shane then they're
able to harness the power of the
totality and they're able to unify it
and when that happens what it does is it
basically allows them to kind of tap
into and kind of create a counterbalance
to perpetual herself and basically
create this sort of metaphysical battle
of like hope versus doom and so what
this means is that the Justice League
themselves are elevated so like a huge
amount of power by being able to harness
this fragment of the totality but at the
same time it's a fight that's not just
them right it's also the various
inhabitants of Earth who are out there
whether or not they're going to side
with or give up on hope and so from
there like you literally have Lex Luthor
who just starts going through and
dismantling all the various members of
the Justice League by channeling all
these various forces that are out there
right so like the ultraviolet forced him
and things like that so he takes out Jon
Stewart the Green Lantern he takes out
the flash Wonder Woman goes to cut him
in half he heals himself and then he
takes out Wonder Woman you know
ultimately he ends up taking out djaro
by basically slicing and which is kind
of nuts like he literally like whips him
and like slices him and then he goes to
take out Batman he breaks his arms and
legs Superman saves him you know but at
the end of the day is just kind of like
all these various heroes are falling
before just Lex Luthor himself as well
as like all the other powers that are
out there and that's why it's kind of
wild is because people are kind of
fluctuating back and forth between being
hopeful and being hopeless hints like
the battle between like Justice and doom
and that's why you kind of see it waxing
and waning and fluctuating the way that
it is and the sense of the heroes are
winning than they're losing and they're
winning and they're losing and they
started to sort of overtake and kind of
get to the point where they basically
start continuing to win and then
Perpetua shows up and when she
does all hope basically fades here and
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because what you end up getting is
basically shame by the son of Martian
Manhunter and in Hawkgirl who steps in
and says okay if we're gonna go in here
and we're gonna fight lex luthor then we
can't fight him head on he's dismantling
all of us let's do what we were supposed
to do let's fight the man right list
happened to the man of Lex Luthor and
that's how it seems to go down and so
ultimately what is it going on here is
Shane basically grabs the attention of
Lex Luthor and then in turn enters his
mind and as soon as he does he basically
starts addressing not Lex Luthor but
Martian Manhunter who's trapped inside
the mind of Lex Luthor and it's one of
the coolest things ever I think is
member Lex Luthor absorbed a Martian
Manhunter and he was believed to have
been dead Hawkgirl has been operating
under that assumption the entire time
there was no real indication he'd be
able to come back and so following that
this conversation that takes place is
absolutely amazing because Martian
Manhunter inside Lex Luthor seems to
have kind of given up now you did get
these moments over the course of this of
this bit of storytelling
we're like he would chime in
occasionally to Lex Luthor and try to
get him to listen but they seemed like
half-hearted measures and seeing Martian
Manhunter as a child really kind of
speaking with this this child version of
himself
Shane basically says like you're the
greatest of them all right you're the
greatest superhero of them all they need
you you can unite the world in a way
that nobody else can right would
perpetual being here with her basically
dominating and scaring the crap out of
the world people kind of siding with do
more or less being influenced in that
way you're the only one of us who can go
out there and unite the minds of all the
world and get them to stand as one
against Perpetua alongside all the
superheroes and so what you get here is
probably one of the greatest returns of
a character in the history of comic
books right so like the whole time
hawkgirl's freaking out right like the
whole time Hawkgirl freaking out she's
like no Shane Shane don't do it don't do
it don't do it he's like I have to it's
the only way to make this work somebody
has to replace Martian Manhunter you
can't just yank him out right like
somebody has to replace him so Shane
goes in and basically takes the place of
Martian Manhunter lex luthor starts to
kind of almost sort of had this this
like crisis here almost looks like he's
breaking down and then like Martian
Manhunter emerges and he says I am the
Martian Manhunter and now is a time for
justice okay so we are picking up with
the conclusion of scott Snyder's Justice
League and there's actually a character
that's going to appear that I want to
draw your attention to I think it'll
give us some indication as to what's
going on here because if I'm a betting
man here I think this is how DC and
marvels cross
basically starts now what kind of get
through that you know what kind of kind
of talk about that as we go through this
but what this does is it picks up in the
the immediate aftermath of the last
video that we did right the last issue
issue number 38 where Martian Manhunter
had basically returned now in and of
himself Martian Manhunter wasn't really
powerful enough to turn the tide of the
battle right and we expected that I mean
Martian Manhunter is a really really
popular character a lot of people really
really liked him but he himself is not
capable of doing that right because
they're facing off against Perpetua the
creator of the multiverse and so March
and Manhunters just like a stronger
version of Superman it's really what he
is right at the end of the day you
compared him Khan for pound he's
basically Superman except he has
telepathy he can shape-shift and he's
afraid of fire right that's basically
yet between the you know the differ
between the two characters now we know
he's stronger than Superman because of
the old Grant Morrison JLA Comics but at
the end of the day he's not powerful
enough to turn the tide of battle on his
own what makes the Martian Manhunter
important is that this war this this
conflict against perpetual right the
idea of doom versus Hope which is really
what this whole thing has been about in
terms of the the power of Doom
overtaking the power of hope or vice
versa is that it's a battle over the
souls of men right that's that's really
what it is that's one of these things
were this isn't really a conflict that
Justice League can win through sheer
force it's a conflict of what side of
people going to choose right if people
decide to choose the side of the Justice
League to choose the side of justice and
to walk away from doom then ultimately
perpetual will fall whereas of people
side with justice of course the Justin
your Justice League inand the heroes
will essentially win and the Martian
Manhunter pleads his case to humanity
right and basically says it's one of
these things where we are all greater
than the sum of our parts as individuals
we're not necessarily strong what we're
capable we can do things but what makes
us powerful what makes all of you guys
powerful as a fact that working as a
cohesive unit you can all achieve great
things it's really one of these things
were you know perpetual kind of gets the
upper hand on it momentarily and it's
one of the things worthy Schoology kind
of you know reaches out to humanity at
the same time and says like nothing
enough doom is what matters doom is what
will win right like you guys cannot
possibly hope to defeat me and even
tries to use Lex Luthor as a pawn right
and says like tell them like tell them
the truth you know and at the end of the
day Lex Luthor is like you know I'm
sorry and ultimately faith and justice
we're winning out in this particular
kind of mental conflict and so you have
these this kind of you know debate this
kind of discussion going back and forth
not really debate but the Martian man
continuing to kind of plead his case to
people we are all capable of great
things we as superheroes we fight
because your people worth fighting for
right like you are our heroes you know
we look at you guys and we see you as
our heroes do you guys see us as heroes
but it's the opposite way it's the other
way around and so where he pleases case
he continues on over and over and over
again at the end of the day doom wins
that basically humanity turns its back
on heroes and it's one of these
interesting things right because leaving
my own opinions out of this this really
is kind of a critique on society right
is it literally as a a social critique
that humanity in you know chose
individuality and it chose doom over the
superheroes now the reality of this is
this choice was long in coming it was
something that that ultimately would
have taken place and the reason why is
because when your various members of
humanity and you look at superheroes yes
superheroes do good things that's true
but what you see is conflict you see
heroes fighting villains you see cities
getting destroyed you see collateral
damage you see people kind of asking the
question why do we need heroes at all
but the real big thing here is that
people are basically reaching down and
looking to their most base desires
they're not really looking at what they
can achieve they're looking at what they
are in the here and now and that's one
of the things that's kind of intriguing
because it's easy to paint humanity as
as villains right it's easy to look at
the story and say okay the true villains
of this story are people it's the
average Joe right it's the average
individual out there who if given the
choice will always choose the worst
version of themselves and people do that
because it's easy to do it's much much
easier to just give up than it is to
keep trying is easy to say that but the
reality is that when it comes to
humanity that the overriding factor here
the overriding thing is fear and that's
ultimately what was being fed on by
Perpetua as ultimately what was really
being being fed on by her and the forces
of doom is the fear of people that
people were afraid but the funny thing
about this is that when perpetuo really
kind of chimes in what she says is that
this is all going exactly the way that
it was supposed to that everything is
transpired has transpired exactly
because she wanted it to she wanted the
Martian Manhunter to plead his case to
humanity she wanted all of this to take
place everything that's happened has
happened
according to her design and she knew
that ultimately humanity was going to
choose the side of doom and the reason
why she makes this argument release it
seems like the reason why she makes this
argument is because all of this exists
partially because of Perpetual right
Perpetua had her version of the
multiverse
that existed and it took the monitor in
the anti-monitor in the forger of world
to team up and basically imprison her
inside the source wall and then recreate
the multiverse as it exists right now
but all the inhabitants of the
multiverse all the humans that exist out
there are basically branched off in some
former fashion of humans or Martians
right every single entity that exists
out there is branched off of either
humans or Martians because at one point
in time in the the multiverse that
Perpetua created is that you kind of had
a pets predators right humans and
Martians were a singular entity and so
when when this was kind of wiped away
when they ultimately split it was wiped
away and then all new life was created
in this multiverse the apex predators
were basically split right so every
iteration of a Martian you see is based
off the original Martians and every
single human that you see is of course
based off humans as they were split as
they were previously apex predators and
so what this means and this kind of
confuses you a little bit what this
basically means is that in the eyes of
perpetual or at least in the eyes of a
you know the way it exists now that if
humans and Martians were originally a
singular being that when they split
humans were basically the weaker side
right and Martians were the more
powerful side and so what this meant is
that humanity as a race is inherently
weak and the reason why that matters is
because it shows us why it is humanity
chose its baser lines in the first place
because when confronted by fear what do
people do people panic they usually give
in to it right that's the social
critique coming into play the idea that
when bad things happen people just want
to wait until it goes away you know
really crazy political environments
people are just like well I'll just wait
until things get better right it just
I'll stick my head in the sand and
hopefully when I stick my head back up
things will be okay
it's the nature of people right it's a
nature of human being so usually kind of
take the easy way out the lazy way out
and did not really confront their own
ended with individual fears on a regular
basis and so when given the option to
either confront their fear and to push
back and see what happens or to give up
humanity chose to give up and it's not
just humans that do that right is every
single race across the cosmos that's
done that and that's the exact point the
repel will makes you never had a chance
to win because what you're asking of
humanity is too much you're asking
humanity to be brave and that's
something the humanities just not really
capable of doing and so what is up
happening is she basically cleanses all
the superheroes of the earth right like
they're all basically gone you know
seemingly wipes out all of the earth
superheroes
takes all the very superheroes that we
saw from the different timelines and
back to their own individual timelines
and so as a result of that it's it's
really kind of left to believe the idea
that the Justice League has been
eradicated from all of existence only
for us to kind of see these sort of
green you know particles more or less
coalescing and in the rebirth of the
Martian Manhunter and when the Martian
Manhunter arrives on the moon completely
clad in black he reaches out with his
telepathy to try to communicate with
earth but he can't write he can't talk
to earth anybody he's really just kind
of an isolation and then he's met by the
other members of the Justice League and
they're like we don't really know
exactly what's going on but they cannot
hear us the indication seems to be that
they've basically been without their
powers the only person with that being
the case is of course Hawkgirl because
she has physical wings but Superman
doesn't really seem to be able to fly
Riaan Lantern Jon Stewart doesn't really
have its ring anymore you know it seems
like none of them really have their
powers or abilities Superman actually
tries to fly and just lands back down on
the surface of the Moon right so he
doesn't really have his powers anymore
and it's one of these things where Jon
Jones kind of internalizes that and says
I saw all this coming I knew this was
going to happen I knew we were going to
lose only for the group to be met with
the arrival of the quintessence now the
quintessence is in a lot of ways a
stand-in for the sky fathers from Marvel
Comics right in Marvel Comics
you've got the sky father as a council
of godheads whatever you want to call
them but it's like Odin Zeus and all the
various earthly cosmic entities or I
guess you know godly entities that
exists out there in DC this is kind of a
larger you know in terms of the role
they play right like the Phantom
Stranger is not a god people pray to
write Shazam is not really a god that
people pray to you my father isn't a god
they pray to you or anything like that
but Hera is right you know she's a God
as the people pray to you so it's really
more of just really powerful entity so
it's not a direct it's not a not a
lateral comparison but it's comparable
but one of the things that I want you to
kind of notice here is that you have the
wizard Shazam and the wizard Shazam does
not look like the new 52 version of his
character he looks totally different
look at the classic version that kind of
begs the question if the quintessence is
is universal meaning that every universe
has its own version of the quintessence
or Pierce - then why does Shazam appear
differently here the difference and this
is where things get a little murky is
highfather for example is a multiversal
character right in all the multiverse
there's only one high father that's why
things are kind of murky for DC because
they're multiversal Oren and Universal
organizational structure is not like
Marvel's is right mom was I think
there's a lot more clean-cut and a lot
more organized and structured
DC's is just all over the damn place so
like we have no real clue who don't know
what the Phantom Stranger is it's
literally he lives up to his name say
he's just like this phantom stranger
that no one really knows anything about
maybe he's the presence maybe he's not
we don't really know it's just the
Phantom Stranger and like he's really
powerful and you can do some stuff The
Phantom Stranger explained that's
basically what that is right and so
because of that the quintessence
basically reveals to the Justice League
that the intention of Perpetua wants to
actually wipe them all out it was to
destroy them and remove them but what
they've done is essentially pluck them
out of reality right so technically
they're in the universe but they're out
of phase with everything else right so
if you were an astronaut looking at the
moon you wouldn't really see them right
now right because they're kind of out of
phase with you oh they're not really in
reality it just looks like they are and
the reason why the quintessence did this
is because there's kind of this hidden
truth across the multiverse that nobody
seems to be aware of and nobody seems to
know about right this truth of the
multiverse that is yet to be revealed to
everyone and because that the Justice
League are in a position to where they
can go find that hidden truth and reveal
it to everybody we don't know exactly
what it'll be but we kind of get these
small little things here in there the
character of Leviathan the events of
Doomsday Clock one of the funny things
about Doomsday Clock isn't really look
like we're given a definitive answer
when Doomsday Clock takes place in
relation to this the fact that we're
shown a panel from Doomsday Clock seems
to show that like it's already happened
but like we don't really know if it's in
the same universe or not that's the
confusion behind all this we don't
really know how all this kind of ties
together but with regards to the wizard
Shazam and looking at him I would argue
that this probably takes place in a
different reality like that's my that's
my knee-jerk reaction is essentially
Scott Steiners run takes place in a
different universe I don't know right
we're not really given a definitive
answer we're left to believe it's in the
main DC universe right I mean there's
really been nothing to indicate that
it's not in the main DC universe but
essentially a kind of doors open up
right and I kind of statements made by
the spectre you guys can enter into this
space and you can pursue this hidden
truth but understand if you find the
answer to it but it'll change everything
right it'll completely alter and change
everything now what you end up having is
a Justice League racing into this kind
of doorway and we kind of have to wait
and see what happens next
and Greg Capullo and Scott Snyder's
metal but my perception here this is
kind of my my thought process here we
know that Marvel and DC are going to
crossover
we know that perpetual was sent by
basically the judge of the worlds right
the cosmic judges more or less to create
you know the the cosmos to create a
multiverse and then all the universes
that exist within that multiverse that
means there are multiple multiverses out
right because one one of the things that
was established here is that Perpetua
was just one of many individuals who
were sent out there into this massive
chasm this massive void of whatever this
space was and then was told to create
multiverses right so she made her
multiverse other beams made their
multiverses and Perpetua seem to be the
only one who wanted to use the the
individual she created inner multiverse
to destroy the cosmic judges my argument
here my thought process here is the one
above all in Marvel Comics is kind of an
equal to Perpetua right like the one
above all was sent by the cosmic judges
to create the multiverse and so it's
there now that's kind of how it oversees
everything I mean that's kind of my
thought process reconciling that with
the knowledge of the one above all and
how its role functions within the
greater Marvel landscape is gonna be
kind of tough to do because one above
all is so ambiguous right to this day
including jim Starlin infinity finale
the one above all i think has made 18 or
19 appearances in Marvel Comics if that
has been referenced more times but not
not even not even 18 or 19 I think it's
in in some form of fashion it's made 18
or 19 appearances in terms of actually
showing up is showing up like three
times right that's that's the only the
only time I'm aware of
there was a time in the Fantastic Four
when it appeared to the Fantastic Four
themselves and look like Jack Kirby the
second time when it appeared to
spider-man and then there was a third
time when it told Adam warlock and
infinity finale that it could be the New
Living Tribunal and then it made Adam
warlock and the New Living Tribunal
those are the only three times I'm aware
of it actually showing up right so the
one above all is ambiguous as hell and
what better way to kind of basically
establish this secret truth this hidden
truth is that there are a slew of
multiverses out there and the Marvel
multiverse is one of them then to
basically say that what you have here is
the one above all creating its
multiverse around the same time that you
are created in and basically having like
all these different giant multiverse
concepts crossing over with each other I
don't know right I'm grasping at straws
here folks don't really have any
definitive answers I'm just kind of
spitballing and theorizing as best I can
but it's a cool idea right it's a cool
concept but either way it's an
interesting end right because what we do
is we're gonna jump over or at least
when when this ends you go into Robert
VIN Diddy's run as far as I'm aware it's
not going to pick up from this right as
far as I'm aware this whole thing right
here is going to pick up with like metal
from Scott Snyder and and Greg Capullo I
don't know what Robert VIN did his run
is gonna look like right I'm kind of
curious myself but would it be said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explained
to make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph been John h aj Matt in
Jeff are John H lean and mean which is
an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin be Adam
K and Genesis 9:6 team you remember guys
you can send me messages and I'll run
off whatever your message is at the end
of the video so long it is nothing crazy
but if you want to put a message in
there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]